Hassan Minaj hit piece in the New Yorker
and there's nothing about this that does
not interest me people were defending
him in the beginning using my name being
like well Anthony J like's jokes aren't
true why does his have to be I think if
you change the joke to make your make it
funnier great no one's going to get mad
at a comic for doing that if you change
the joke to make yourself like a hero in
the eyes of the people who will not be
denied in his quest for justice it's a
problem and I've enjoyed watching it all
I have never met ham Minaj I did not
know him I don't think we have any
friends in common but I have enjoyed
watching this happen if he puts out
another statement I'm there for it what
was his initial statement that like my
comedy Arnold Palmer is 70% like this
really happened and 30% emotional truth
which is Comics do talk like this my
comedy arold Arnold Palmer is uh 70%
this really happened 30% piss drink it
up you tickets still left in
Baltimore and Cleveland